what emerged over the last 10 years was
a new class of investors I really think
of them as investing in quasi public
companies they have a self-interest in
keeping these companies private for a
long time because like private Equity
they can continue to put more and more
capital in it's like a private club for
public market companies that only 50
people can compete for it's a much
better market for you to make money in
than the actual Public Market I don't
think it's better for the founders I
don't think it's better for the
companies strip bite dance SpaceX all of
these companies could be public as
Amazon as Google as Salesforce and so
many others have proven this idea that
you can't innovate in the public markets
is total nonsense it's a cheap source of
capital it keeps the business efficient
and honest and so my sense is that
you're going to see the markets really
open up in 24 and 25 we have a backlog
because we've had almost no IPOs over
the course of the last two years IPO
markets are always wide open it's just a
matter of price